[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'un des liens qui m'unissent au
territoire c'est c'est bien malgré moi
et j'en suis fort heureuse au québec
quand je me présente c'est rarement aux
petits fruits auquel on pense bien que
la mirabelle d'un d'excellentes
confitures et une douce eau de vie au
québec
quand je me présente les gens disent
plutôt à mirabel comme larivot par mèche
d'objets tir oui car mon prénom est
intimement liée à ce coin de pays
l'ema mère habitait saint scolastique
près de mirabel où elle a vécu des jours
heureux jusqu'au jour est obligé de
déménager parce qu'elle été expropriés
mais malgré tout c'est en souvenir des
jours heureux tellement près d'1 min
rabin mais aujourd'hui le développement
des territoires j'en fais mon métier
y'a pas dire j'ai même été agent de
voyages
la notion de territoire peut être floue
puis avec raison par exemple pendant le
bâtiment dans lequel vous habitez mais
ce bâtiment là et sur une rue la manière
des poupées russes
ses rues la forme un quartier qui à leur
tour forme des villes qui alors pour
femmes des régions qui forment des
provinces et ensemble pays jusqu'au
continent
mais ce sont là des territoires mme à
différentes échelles mais c'est vrai que
à notre naissance ont choisi par notre
prénom mais on ne choisit pas non plus
le lieu de notre naissance mais il en va
autrement en vieillissant parce que
jours c'est souhaité quand on quitte le
nid familial et c'est peut-être la
première fois où on est confronté à
savoir où on veut aller habiter mais
rêvons les plus guère la carte du mans
est sous nos yeux
quels seront vos critères est ce que
vous voulez rester près de votre famille
ou pas ce que vous vouliez suivre votre
conjoint ou conjointe ou c'est pour des
raisons de formation puis en sachant que
le territoire pourra pas répondre à
l'ensemble de nos besoins
mais peut-être que vous n'avez pas le
choix de faire dès qu'on prend
mais quel compromis êtes vous prêt à
faire lesquels sont immuables pellicules
sont négociables
seriez vous prêt à changer de vocation
simplement parce que la formation dont
vous avez besoin ne se donne pas dans
votre ville ou bien est-ce que vous ça
vous dérange à faire une heure de
voiture pour aller travailler
peut-être pas peut-être que oui
peut-être que non mais ce sont là des
choix bien personnel tout comme le sont
aussi les raisons qui nous poussent à
partir ou à rester mais parmi l'un des
critères qui m'interpelle le plus c'est
celui de choisir un environnement où on
va pouvoir s'identifier
puis identité de territoire mais on le
capt à tous les jours il suffit
d'imaginer au chalet dans une ville ou
sur une terrasse ensoleillée
tantôt au mois de février
tantôt en plein été mais la vue de ces
images
ça le fait appel à votre imaginaire vous
avez ressenti des émotions
peut-être même un petit caisson de froid
mais c'est exactement ça l'identité d'un
territoire se forge avec son climat sa
position géographique ou dans l'époque
dans lequel ils évoluent sont des
éléments intangibles comme ça sacré
d'identité c'est l'adn ce territoire
mais des éléments aussi tangible qui
existent si je vous présente la tour
eiffel le château frontenac où le parc
guell jeu paumelle certaine que vous
avez été capable d'identifier que c'est
dans la ville de paris à québec ou à
barcelone
ce sont là des marqueurs identitaires
dans le cadre bâti d'un territoire
on pourrait faire le même exercice avec
des personnes ici à chiang maï en
thaïlande
juste avec le faciès et les us et
coutumes des gens on est capable de
savoir où ils viennent c'est la même
chose aussi pour des personnes d'un même
province avec les expressions verbales à
ce moment là on est capable de savoir
juste l'expression
ils viennent tous la même chose aussi
pour les personnalités soient si on
pense à fred pellerin pour
saint-élie-de-caxton ou gilles vigneault
pour natashquan qu'on évoque ces gens là
on fait tout de suite des associations
territoire mais des fois notre
territoire est presque aussi important
que notre prénom
par exemple un animateur dans les lignes
ouvertes
la première chose qui demande évidemment
c'est quelle est votre nom mais tout de
suite la deuxième question c'est de quel
endroit nous à pied vous donne un autre
exemple séquence présent soit dans une
réunion où dans une sphère l'endroit où
on habite arrive bien souvent dans la
discussion qui s'est passé paul et les
modes dans blick ont dit être tout de
suite c'est le premier élément qu'on va
convaincre conventionnés et vous quel
aurait été votre réponse à l'animateur
est ce que vous auriez d'emblée divo le
nom de votre rue de votre quartier ou de
votre ville mais c'est comme le signe du
berthe achement son territoire qu'en
parlant d'attachement je vais vous
demander de choisir un territoire de le
garder quelques instants en pet déjà
vous pouvez vous demander pourquoi vous
avez choisi ce territoire là c'est
certainement parce que vous vous sentez
bien
vous le trouvez hospitalier votre
territoire ou bien vous le trouvez
attractif parce qu'un jour vous voulez
aller le visiter où vous allez vous
établir si je vous demandais aujourd'hui
de convaincre votre voisin que votre
territoire est meilleur que le sien
qu'est ce que vous feriez vous ferez
appel à des notions de marketing
parce qu'à la base le marketé c'est un
moyen de communiquer avec ses
consommateurs
mais en marketing territorial le
consommateur sait nous citoyens
investisseurs touristes en sachant qu'un
territoire en sachant que là une
personne avant avoir ses propres
critères pour déménager ou choisir un
une ville mais il va falloir savoir
qu'est ce que lui ou elle pense mais va
falloir se poser vers un point et pour
qui voulons nous que le territoire se
démarque
est ce que c'est la présence d'un
montagne où son centre-ville animé ou un
centre de recherche mais ça dépasse
votre télé si votre voisin est jeune ou
un sportif ou un chercheur mais encore
là vous avez bien beau vanter les
mérites de votre territoire à qui mieux
mieux
c'est votre voisin ne connaît même pas
où se trouve votre territoire vous êtes
mal parti pour le convaincre
si je vous dis que j'habite sainte
famille mais peut-être que pour vous le
savez que ça l'île d'orléans
mais je t'ai théologique dire que c'est
l'île d'orléans c'est peut-être que si
vous connaissez pas encore l'île
d'orléans j'avais pu obliger encore de
spécifier que ce qu'il est c'est à ce
moment là puis il faut savoir aussi est
ce que votre territoire et connus ou pas
mais ce qui est connu pour les bonnes
raisons
il ya quand même une différence en est
ce que vous tapez le nom de votre tapis
le nom de votre ville sur internet puis
vous voyez les premiers résultats
qu'est ce qui en sort puis aussi est-ce
que le palmarès est ce que votre ville
et dans le top 10 des villes le du
bonheur ou le top 10 des villes de
corruption c'est pas le même attachement
qu'on appelait la perception est
différente aussi une influence notre
territoire de plusieurs façons le
territoire nos influences qu'on ait une
influence le territoire effectivement en
influence de territoire et répondre
influence pardon par son climat
on est au québec en hiver prêt pas prêt
il en à neige puis ça n'influence à
notre façon de vivre mais nous aussi on
peut influencer notre territoire
par sa façon qu'on peut influencer sa
gouvernance en allant voter ou en
participant aux consultations publiques
on peut aussi l'influencé ont peu
influencé son dynamisme en participant
aux festivités ou en implantant son
entreprise ou tout simplement en
s'impliquant dans une cause qui nous est
cher parce que tout ça est relié
puis vous trouvez votre territoire
escaliers
vous voulez vous investir je puis vous
voulez vous investir vous avez un
élément de fierté et vous en parlez vous
voulez le vendre à votre voisin va vous
donner des ambassadeurs un peu comme
l'athlète aux jeux olympiques ou des
influenceurs serein sur internet étant
donné que vous influencer votre
territoire qui vous en parler avec
fierté notre territoire devient
attractif tout est relié fait finalement
ce qu'on peut se poser c'est encore que
nous entamons territoire peut devenir un
élément de fierté d'hospitalité et
d'attractions puis finalement la
question qu'on peut se poser c'est
est-ce qu'on a vite finalement dans un
territoire où on peut s'identifier
est ce que vous avez réussi à convaincre
votre voisin mais souhaitons nous dans
tous les cas d'influencer positivement
nos territoires pour qu'il soit à
l'image de notre personnalité de notre
adn
merci
[Applaudissements]